give me your like r b
top three who's your top three rb artist
all time man like yours not not who you
think everyone else will like but like
your personal favorites
uh uh
i feel like you know what i'm saying
justin r kelly
no i'm saying shout out to r kelly we
got hey can we get it can we can we can
we just
i just want to give our kelly flowers
yes he is not a good human being but he
[ __ ] is the greatest of all time
yeah nobody wants it in the verses
nobody
you know what i'm saying let me see
uh i wanna can i sit can i consider uh
michael michael michael jackson
uh another quite possibly
not great human being but great artists
you know what i mean
so far we're two for three on uh on the
on
yeah and uh on the toxic guys
and uh let me see let me see
[Music]
r b michael jackson's probably more pop
though to be fair
i feel like you know i feel like who a
lot of people sleep on that i uh
really really enjoy is uh part of next
door
oh party's one of the best writers of
the last like 25 years
yeah no for sure for sure yeah now his
pen game is ridiculous what's your
favorite part i can't say three though
beyonce you know beyonce's up there
uh sure uh uh
for sure like yeah it's it's it's a few
what's your favorite r kelly album
double up
double up yeah wait double up yeah yeah
yeah yeah that jungle
i feel like i feel like the generic
answer is always 12 play
yeah i ain't i don't think i even never
heard you never heard 12 play no
oh man what
i just go through i got [ __ ] on right
now i just know all these songs but i
don't i ain't
half on a baby oh